TAPE IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE, IT IS
ZACH PARISE.
ANDERS LEE YIELDS 2 BROCK
TO DOBSON.
FIRES
WHAT WAS THE CALL?
DID THEY SAY IT WAS MCAVOY
IMPROVE YOUR ANGLE.
AND WITH THE BERGERON W
AVAILABLABLE, GOALS IN
GAMES.
NOW -- .
>>
[CHEERING]
THE BRUINS HAVE
SCORED WN DEEP.
WE JUST TALKED YOU
MARCHAND TRIES
FORECHECK.
THERE IS MARSHAWN.
FREDERICK, A SAVE
BY OH MARK.
AND HANDLE
ON.
IT.
IT ALLOWS US HE
ALLOWS A 2ND CHANCE
CHANCE THE
LET THE AND
ATTACK RIGHT DOWN
THE MIDDLE OF THE
ICE.
CREATE YOUR 2 ON
ONE, GET THE PUCK
AND L.A.. UNCES ARE
THE
THE FORECHECK.
PULOCK, PALMIERI
CLOSES ACROSS TO
MAYBE BATTLER A
LITTLE BIT BY
FREDERIC ROTATING
BACK.
I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT HITS THE